protests in Iran have been taking place
across the country following the death
of a woman in police custody Iran's
so-called morality police had arrested
her for not wearing her hijab correctly
demonstrators refused to back down
despite a brutal response by authorities
the fundamentalist Shiite government is
calling on people to stop the protests
but so far the calls have had little
effect
the people versus the state
so far Iranian authorities are holding
firm
that's the elite revolutionary guards
who control most of the economy and
security and the clerics led by supreme
leader Ayatollah who make the rules
officials say the unrest is the work of
foreign agents especially the US and
Israel
why did our enemies why did America and
the Zionist regime conspire against our
country and our Revolution to create
these riots as the supreme leader said
our country is advancing and the enemies
don't want our country to make progress
for their part protesters aren't just
angry about one policy they're rejecting
the whole regime a regime that has not
tried to accommodate them instead the
head of the Revolutionary guards has
tried to play Down the level of public
discontent
we are telling our youth the minority
who have been deceived to stop Wicked
acts today is the end of the riots don't
go to the streets anymore
[Applause]
protests of the past this time around
students have been joined by working
class crowds a broad-based loose
Alliance that threatens the regime's
base of support
burning hijabs and attacking police
stations rejecting the authority of the
security services and the religious
rules of the clerics
the challenge for Iran's rulers is to
manage the protests without setting off
more unrest that's a difficult balance
and it's one that it's far from clear
the government is capable of
uh joining us now is Cornelius Alaba
Iran expert and political analyst at the
center for European policy studies here
in Berlin now how stable do you think is
the Iranian regime right now
Well for now we we have to say uh that
it is holding the line um the protests
have been going on for weeks already
they have maintained I would say a base
level
um these are not Millions to take into
the streets but there are hundreds and
thousands uh going uh for marches every
day throughout the entire country and as
you've said um these are people from
almost all walks of life so this is this
is uh considerable this is uh
threatening uh the the basis of the
regime people are shouting death to the
dictator so this is not about you know
higher pay or better living conditions
but this is fundamentally about what the
Islamic Republic is about but as I say
so far the regime is is crashing it and
they are putting out their their riot
control uh guards and they are holding
the line um we we have to to see that
this is the the situation at the moment
okay they're holding the line for the
moment but do you think the protest
movement could actually pose a real
threat to the regime
well I do think that it could um we
needed a couple of more ingredients for
this uh to be an actual threat um like
uh having uh higher numbers of people
taking to the street
um having more of a coherent
organization behind this and and
ultimately having some
um like a program some some things uh
some demands that they can put out there
which also show to to the regular people
if I can say so those who are not
demonstrating but who may sympathize
um showing them that there is an
alternative um because for now I mean
the revolution is a little over 40 years
ago but this is all that people know and
in the past all these these riots and
protests they have been put down
um so you have to really convince the
majority of the people uh that there is
an actual alternative that things can be
different from what they know for the
past four decades
now Iran is an important Regional power
how the protests views in neighboring
countries
Regional Rivals and if I can say so so
um you know they are wary I would like
to say um of course some may may uh
secretly um have a desire uh to see the
the regional arrival in in trouble
um and to see it engulf in these Street
protests they may even wish for some
kind of regime change but then again you
know a popular protests turning violent
is not a recipe that they would like to
to have in their own country so a
successful Revolution let alone a
successful Democratic liberal
revolutionist as many people outside the
country wish for
um this would not be a good omen for for
the more authoritarian regimes in the
region so they they are careful I would
like to say
Cornelius there from the center for
European studies here in Berlin thank
you very much
thank you
an Israeli musician whose songs in Farsi
have made her one of the voices of
Iran's protest movement lira's Shari was
born in Israel to Iranian parents as an
Israeli she is not allowed to enter Iran
and the internet has allowed her music
to cross borders where she can't but
today her songs are doing more than
connecting cultures they've become a
soundtrack for the anti-regime protest
sweeping through Iran
together we'll start a revolution how
much longer will we be quiet keep our
heads down our knees bent
outrageous words from the point of view
of the Iranian regime
from a singer seen as equally outrageous
is Jewish an Israeli and sings in Farsi
the official language of Iran
it's really not about me
uh I had the choice to sing in Farsi to
spread the word of the women in Iran
that are muted until today since
Revolution they are not able
to do this you know pure simple thing
and it's to sing La Ross was born in
Israel to Jewish Iranian parents who had
to leave their Homeland in Israel liraz
is a well-known actress and pop singer
switching from singing in Hebrew to
singing in Farsi posed a risk to her
career
even riskier was her idea to work with
Iranian musicians in Tehran
[Music]
collaboration that was initially online
but for her new album they met secretly
in a basement studio in Istanbul
[Music]
was a day that they left and I needed to
record last song I I couldn't sing I
lost my voice I felt like I'm doing this
big mistake and until they got home I
couldn't breathe it was tough
now her music has become part of
protests in Iran every day she receives
messages and videos of Iranian women
breaking the law to dance to her music
without headscarves or pictures of
anti-regime demonstrations set to her
songs
every time I ask myself why are we doing
what we're doing is this so important
and I said to myself yeah because it's
not only music it's a message
a woman taking a stand for freedom in
Iran yesterday she sang at a club in
Hamburg one of many stops on her world
tour
but her greatest wish is to sing in Iran
one day soon
[Music]